Ukrainian troops are still fiercely
defending a city that Russia says it is
nearly captured Ukrainian troops in
bakmut say they inflicted heavy
casualties on Russia's military over the
weekend after months of fighting the
city has become a symbol of Ukraine's
Defiance MTS types spoke with residents
in a neighboring Town who fear they
could be Russia's next Target
good morning bakboot is just around one
mile from this Ukrainian position but
it's a tense standoff as Russian and
Ukrainian forces continue to suffer from
ammunition shortages and mounting
casualties
the horrors being waged in buckmut are
being described as hell on Earth
but Ukrainian forces are putting up a
fierce resistance as both suffer
enormous losses
this one's sleepy town is now a Garrison
town and when or if bakmut Falls
this is next
it's here we meet 85 year old antonina
whenever I leave my home I pray to God
she says I pray I can get some bread and
not get killed along the way
at an aid center locals are being
encouraged to evacuate
inside the Aid Center we meet Sasha and
Ludmila who've been married for 46 years
Sasha tells us his health is
deteriorating fast and he's ready to go
but Ludmila just can't bring herself to
abandon her life do you support your
husband's decision to leave while you
stay here yes yes yes you do
you must be so difficult though
it's hard she says
I Will Survive I am strong
but as they make their way to the car
that will take Sasha to safety it's too
much
don't cry
you should come with me
now Ludmila didn't leave she stayed
behind to care for her animals but in
chasive Yar what may once have seen like
a small sacrifice is now one of life or
death received this morning on the
buckmut front lines